[Musique]
du
jacky teisseire vous voyez il faut
rester député aldo nf1
1978 et sur fond de chômage
[Musique]
bah déjà moi mon travail c'était
sylviculteurs polyvalent donc on faisait
la réalisation des sentiers les aires de
pique nique du freinage la petite
maçonnerie et tous les travaux qui
touchent à l'équipement des sites
touristiques
on a réalisé les sentiers qui fend de
ravine bras-sec go qui thon rouge depuis
thon rouge à petit benare de petit
benare gambela une partie aussi piton
rouge la glacière ont travaillé avec une
équipe de huit ou neuf ouvriers on
dormait sous les grottes delà de la
fontaine d'une cave est dans notre
jargon à nous c'était bien c'était la
belle époque on partait le lundi on
était hébergé sur place dans les
conditions que je vienne cité et ont
retourné à la maison le vendredi le
moyen de locomotion
c'était le personnel et le paquet sur le
dos le soir lorsque la genette
travailler et terminé les gens tueuse
retrouvés et on veut une petite belote
sous la table avant de prendre le
matelas pour dormir dessus
suis à la recherche d'une conciliation
jeu suivi pas de nature non plus à
laisser marcher sur les pieds pour la
bonne cause et de l'intérêt général
je suis l'interlocuteur privilégié en
qualité de représentant du personnel
et cela depuis 37 ans maintenant je suis
conseiller prud'homal et administrateur
à la caisse d'allocations familiales et
depuis je suis aussi un représentant au
niveau national pour le personnel de
l'office national des forêts s'est
redonné lohan est flat pas cela l'avait
à une époque en qualité de main d'oeuvre
on traverse une période de baisse des
effectifs qui est voulu par le
gouvenement devenir des ouvriers
forestiers risque de disparaître que le
f reprenne sa place et que le maximum
des travaux soirée soit réalisée en
riches
[Musique]